[Music]
on this Saturday night strain from the
strike at BC ports there's more
uncertainty after unionized workers
voted down the latest deal first it was
the strike now it's the backlog it's
gonna take weeks now Federal action
could be looming to end the labor
dispute
World Police and Fire Games Under Fire
why critics say Hong Kong police
shouldn't be at the global competition
in Winnipeg
people visit one year later the steps
survivors and Indigenous communities are
still waiting to see
and a color Crusader it's more than how
do I make money it's actually more how
do I make art accessible the artist
liberating commodified color for
everyone
global national with foreign Esser
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin on the west coast tonight where
it's back to the bargaining table poor
workers in BC voted down a mediated deal
to end a simmering labor dispute that
sparked a 13-day strike earlier this
month the initial job action cost the
Canadian economy billions stalling goods
and causing gridlock at some of Canada's
biggest and busiest ports and tonight
the pressure is on Port workers look set
to head back to the picket lines and
it's raising questions about whether the
federal government will step in and
enforce back-to-work legislation Mike
drolet has our top story tonight
the busiest port in Canada was anything
but business as usual today workers
clocked in but how long will they stay
on the job after rejecting a mediated
contract offer weeks after a crippling
13-day strike cost businesses billions
in trade we cannot pay the price of
another strike because the the price we
paid during the first strike was
extremely high and so we need both
parties to come to an agreement and
within the union to uh realize that it
is irresponsible for them to keep the
economy in hostage
7400 BC port workers walked off the job
July 1st affecting 30 ports a mediated
deal was tentatively agreed to but the
union still expressed concern over job
security and after its members voted no
the union now says it wants our direct
employers to come to the table and
negotiate in lieu of the BC Maritime
employers Association in response the
bcmea called the Union's actions erratic
and released details of the deal
including a wage increase of 19.2
percent over four years which would see
the median Longshore salary rise from
136 000 to 162 000 per year not
including benefits and pension
43 percent of all cargo shipped to
Canada goes through the port of
Vancouver after the 13-day strike ended
the Vancouver Board of Trade reported a
backlog of 63 000 shipping containers
that needed to be unloaded with CN
saying it would take over two months for
it to catch up both prime minister
Trudeau and Shima sarigan said that
another strike was not an option for
workers to go back on strike the union
would have to issue a 72-hour notice
however labor Minister Sheamus origin
says he's using his authority to
preserve industrial Peace by directing
the industrial Relations Board to impose
either a new Collective Agreement or
final binding arbitration the message
being BC ports need to stay open
microwave Global News
yeah
working people at grocery stores are
just not making ends meet
there's another labor dispute playing
out this one on the east coast
3700 workers at 27 Toronto area grocery
stores walked off the job this morning
after rejecting a tentative contract
agreement that initially averted strike
action earlier this month Metro workers
are pushing for better pay benefits and
working conditions staff say inflation
and the cost of living has hit so hard
they can't even afford the food they're
selling at those stores and they're
having to turn to food banks for support
some troubling news coming from Alberta
tonight RCMP have confirmed six people
on board a small plane are dead after it
crashed in kananasca's country late last
night the plane went down about five
kilometers north of kananascus Village
which is 100 kilometers north of Calgary
the Piper pa-32 aircraft took off from
Calgary's Spring Bank airport around 9
pm Friday on its way to Salmon Arm BC a
search team was sent in after it was
reported overdue RCMP say the bodies
have been recovered two investigators
from the Transportation safety board
have been deployed to investigate the
case a firefighter in BC has died
battling a wildfire in the provinces
North BC Wildfire service says it
happened on Friday in the province's
Prince George fire Center region RCMP
Say the 25 year old wildland firefighter
contracted by a private company from
Ontario was riding on a UTV on a gravel
road when it rolled over a steep drop he
died while being transported to hospital
he is said to have been fighting the
Donny Creek Wildfire BC's largest fire
it's the second firefighter death of the
season in BC and the fourth in Canada
an international competition for police
officers and firefighters is underway in
Winnipeg but the event is coming under
Fire for one of the teams participating
as Mike Armstrong explains critics say
Hong Kong police have been at the center
of China's Crackdown on the
pro-democracy movement and shouldn't
have been invited to take part in the
world police and fire games
[Music]
more than 8 500 police officers and
firefighters are facing off an
olympic-style competitions in Winnipeg a
week and a half long event has attracted
teams from more than 70 countries
China isn't participating but a team
from Hong Kong is I was shocked and I
couldn't see how this would happen
Margaret mcquig Johnston is with the
China strategic risks Institute
and says someone made a mistake when
Hong Kong police started cracking down
on pro-democracy leaders in 2019 Canada
suspended extradition agreements with
the Hong Kong police force Amnesty
International says they've been involved
in arbitrary arrests beatings and
torture why would we be rolling out the
red carpet and having a big celebration
of their prowess
I just can't I I can't see it
now the protests in Hong Kong may have
stopped but the repression hasn't
earlier this month police arrested four
men it accused of supporting dissidents
outside the country it also announced
bounties and arrest warrants against
eight foreign-based activists some of
those Exiles are now based in Washington
and part of a group called the Hong Kong
democracy Council
that group tweeted out this video of
Hong Kong police being booed by
protesters in Winnipeg Friday night it
says it's quote disgusting to see Hong
Kong police marching freely in Canada it
says the force quote brutalized and
oppressed so many Hong kongers on behalf
of their Chinese Communist Party Master
Canada it says should know better we are
a non-political entity and so we don't
have the ability to comment or decide
who does and doesn't come organizers say
they were following the federal
government's guidance Ottawa has
criticized what's going on in Hong Kong
but people are still free to travel back
and forth that includes to these games
Mike Armstrong Global News
[Music]
the U.S has announced 345 million
dollars in military aid for Taiwan it's
the first major package drawing on
America's own stockpiles to help Taiwan
counter China U.S President Joe Biden
says the package will include Defense
Education and Training for the Taiwanese
lawmakers have been pressuring
Washington to get weapons to Taiwan to
help deter China from attacking the
announcement prompted a swift rebuke
from Beijing which has promised to
reunify democratically ruled Taiwan with
the Chinese Mainland by force if
necessary
coming up the U.S plan to overhaul the
United Nations security Council to
better manage global conflict
a massive explosion at a fireworks
Warehouse in southern Thailand has
killed at least 10 people local
officials say more than 100 others were
injured the warehouse was completely
destroyed as well as several nearby
buildings and houses authorities say
there are still people trapped under
debris waiting to be rescued it's
believed construction work taking place
in the warehouse set off the stored
fireworks
the U.S will assume the presidency of
the United Nations security Council in
August it's the first time it will be at
the helm since Russia's war on Ukraine
began while it has a prime seat at the
table the Biden Administration is hoping
to address growing frustration at the
council's inability to manage global
conflict Jamie Maraca reports it's a
small table the U.S hopes will soon have
more seats those of us on the security
Council have a duty to do more to do
better Russia China the U.S Britain and
France are the five permanent members of
the United Nations security Council with
veto Powers pushing a plan for reform
the Biden Administration is floating
adding six more permanent members to the
Inner Circle without granting those
Nations veto Powers there's mounting
public pressure for change amid the
current council's failure to respond to
Global crises including Russia's
invasion of Ukraine you can't really
expect the security Council to to
handle the Ukraine war very well when
the main aggressor in that war is a
permanent member with a veto which does
then lead to the question of do we even
want to keep this mechanism around
foreign policy fellow Michael O'Hanlon
says it's a smart political play for
Biden to attempt modernization but it
won't be easy the lack of Vetoes isn't
the only issue which countries would get
to join could be contentious
India with its 1.4 billion people would
be a natural
that might anger rival Pakistan in the
developing World particularly Africa
there could be infighting over which
country should get a spot the current
Council has 15 member nations 10 of
which are non-permanent past campaigns
for those temporary seats have seen
intense diplomatic jockeying Canada lost
its most recent bid we don't compete
well we we don't invest in it but it
also means our chances are now Ottawa
University professor John Packer who
worked for the UN in the 80s and 90s
says he thinks the chances for change as
a whole are just as dire you can only
change these things
um like that according to the Charter
itself and so there are certain elements
you can't change you can't really change
the veto power of the five unless they
individually would surrender it which
they're not going to do failure to
respond and adapt to our ever-changing
world could put the council's
credibility and entire purpose into
question Jamie moroccer Global News
ahead revisiting the papal visit one
year later and whether there's been
progress on the Promises to indigenous
people
[Music]
one year ago on this weekend Pope
Francis wrapped up a week-long visit to
Canada in the Pope's own words at the
time it was a penitential pilgrimage
focused on apologizing for the Catholic
Church's role in Canada's residential
school system
Cree Nation Grand Chief Mandy galmasti
joins us now to reflect on the visit one
year later Grand Chief gulmasti thank
you very much for joining us
all right thank you so you were part of
a delegation of indigenous leaders who
visited the Vatican where the pope
delivered the initial apology I believe
you then attended at least two of the
Pope's events in Alberta and Quebec your
home province since then could you
describe what's changed and whether
there's been progress in addressing the
issues that were raised with the Pope
and the Roman Catholic Church
thank you I was a representative of the
province of Quebec
during the time this past year we've
seen the evolution of many activities I
think that the federal government has
announced the special report from the
special interlocutor we saw the
repudiation of the doctrine of Discovery
from the Vatican church we also know
that there was access provided for a
research and some of the oblit archives
there have been some small steps
significant response on the side of the
church I think myself personally I'm
still waiting to see more
how do you think the apology from the
Pope in this time has influenced the
healing process for survivors and their
communities I've had a variety of
responses some residential school
survivors telling me that this was
something that they were looking for the
action of an apology delivered something
for them
some saying that they were not pleased
wanting more not feeling that it was
enough and some not ready to speak about
it yet
you mentioned you're still waiting to
see some more action among the calls
that we heard from various communities
were reparations accountability for
those who perpetrated abuse in those
institutions the return of artifacts
from the Vatican and acknowledgment by
the church of missing and murdered
indigenous women girls and two-spirit
people I'm curious are there any
specific issues or concerns that you
believe need to be prioritized by the
church in its efforts to address the
ongoing effects of residential schools
moving forward
I think first and foremost for myself
seeking access to the archives to any
kind of records for surviving students
and their family having that kind of
information for those children who
didn't return home or their whereabouts
are unknown is important I think that
this should be something that is hosted
by the Vatican that is funded by the
Vatican to have a formal committee set
up for indigenous Nations to participate
for themselves secondly a return of land
repatriation of those students who were
buried in church facilities or on school
grounds in addition I think there has to
be some dialogue a formal process set up
for the return of artifacts that are
held at the Vatican speaking of your
first-hand experience how has your
personal involvement in these events
shaped your perspective on the potential
for reconciliation between the Catholic
church and Indigenous communities
for myself going to the Vatican was a
really challenging experience it was
very it was very hard to hear the
residential school survivors speak about
what they endured how their life was
affected how their further generations
of families were affected and then to
come home and to try to work with my
nation and try to have these really
challenging dialogues is not something
that you could do lightly in my nation
one of the communities that had a
Catholic school has begun the process of
ground penetrating radar they are
investigating the the school lands to
see if there are remains that is
something really hard you know these are
people these are our family members our
friends our relations and for them to
have this discussion something that has
been in the dark for so long I can't
imagine the impact on them as a leader
trying to create that space trying to
support it is something that is very
challenging Every Nation across Canada
is in a different place with that in
terms of seeing the evolution of the
Pope's visit you know watching him
coming to Alberta seeing everything that
happened there watching him coming to
Quebec City that was something really
hard not just to see the impact on the
pope himself but to see the impact that
it had on Canadians and you know what
that dialogue meant for them what did
this visit have in terms of an impact on
indigenous peoples but also what kind of
learning occurred for for Canadians and
experiencing this historic moment
that is Cree Nation Grand Chief Mandy
gullmasti Grand Chief gulmasti thank you
very much
thank you
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress as
a result of their residential school
experience you can call toll-free and
speak in confidence at 1-800-721-0066
[Music]
a seismic show from Taylor Swift how the
artist literally moved the Earth
[Music]
Taylor Swift fans in Seattle took her
musical advice to shake it off literally
during Swift's show before 72 000
concert goers last week she and her fans
were so loud they created seismic
activity equal to Tremors of magnitude
2.3
there is a push to keep another kind of
art form available to the masses big
businesses are increasingly putting a
price on pigment but as Redmond Shannon
discovered for the new reality one
British Artist is campaigning to free
color for fellow creators
Stuart sample lives in a World of Color
I love watching it go in
if Willy Wonka had a paint factory it
would be here in his artist's studio and
paint lab on the south coast of England
eye candy everywhere you look
I would explain color as something that
can change our
emotions and it is our way really of
um feeling the world inside us visually
Stewart's artwork has been exhibited
around the world but his calling is
something bigger so it's more than how
do I make money it's actually more how
do I make art accessible
he does so by developing and selling
affordable quality paints just one arm
of his non-profit art business
but accessing color these days isn't
always as easy as Stuart would like
and I hate the idea that art or color or
materials are sort of gate kept in any
way shape or form most recently Stuart
noticed some digital colors Out Of Reach
now jailed behind a paywall and it took
me about two or three hours and then I'd
created this free-tone plug sorry two or
three hours yeah
yeah to get inside the software yeah and
fix this issue yeah I wanted to make it
better for everybody it was the patch
that people needed so I made it big
business is interested in color too the
commodification of it from UPS Brown to
Home Depot Orange
sample knows blue well enough to make
Tiff his cheeky version of Tiffany blue
it's one of the more protected corporate
colors that he's determined to take back
one brushstroke at a time who owns color
no one can own color color exists it's
it's just a phenomena of nature Redmond
Shannon Global News London
[Music]
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm nitu garcha we'll
leave you tonight with a new way to get
around Montreal
the REM opened its doors for free rides
to the public this weekend for a taste
of the city's new light rail network the
6.9 billion dollar Transit project is
launching with five stations for now but
that's expected to grow into 26 stations
and 67 kilometers of track across the
greater Montreal area thanks so much for
watching hope to see you again tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
thank you